hey David what happens if we tax the
rich too much do they leave the country
do they stop working
okay so let's deal with this question
again there's an idea that is sometimes
presented which is if you tax the rich
too much they won't work anymore because
they won't it won't be worth it for them
they won't keep enough the gut for the
government takes too much of their money
it's not worth working or they will
simply leave the country let's deal with
these one by one first of all if you tax
rich people they will leave the country
anecdotally sure sometimes a rich person
changes where they live sometimes it's
for reasons related to taxation
sometimes it's not the truth is the
number of rich people that would lead
leave the United States if taxes were
somewhat higher we're not talking about
I'm not at least talking about a 90
percent marginal tax rate starting at a
million bucks I don't think that that
there's any evidence that would be good
the number of rich people who leave the
country is relatively small it's going
to be more or less mathematically
insignificant remember that most rich
people want to live in the place where
they have community where their families
are where they speak the language sure
some rich people might leave if you tax
them too much but not at the levels at
which studies suggest the richest
Americans should be taxed so the leaving
the country thing is really quite a big
distraction now what about the
possibility that if you attach tax a
rich person too much they will stop
working here's the thing you know how
they say your that first million is the
toughest that may or may not be true
depending on whether you inherited it or
actually build a business but the
reality is that in the same way that
there's a diminishing marginal utility
to money if you have a billion dollars
another five million does very little
for you if you have a dollar five
million dollars does a lot for you
there's a diminishing marginal utility
for money but for a lot of these super
rich people it's much easier to build
their wealth than it maybe was to get to
where they were let me give you an
example if you have a net worth of a
billion dollars more than likely you can
scale up your business five percent
relatively easily compared to starting a
business from scratch so if you're being
taxed
for example at the seventy-three percent
marginal tax rate on income above 10
million that means if you go from a
billion a year in income to 1.1 billion
a year in income right imagine you grow
your business a hundred million dollars
you might pay seventy three percent on
that additional hundred million but the
relative amount of work that was
required to get that additional hundred
million was far smaller than it was to
build your business to its first hundred
million so there's no question that if
you tax the super-rich ninety five
percent marginal tax rate above a
certain level that likely would be a
disincentive to continue working if it's
as most studies suggests you want to top
it out around seventy or seventy three
percent at very high incomes it is very
unlikely that it will have a significant
effect in terms of getting rich people
to abandon work and in fact the idea is
that balancing everything a top marginal
tax rate around seventy percent would
maximize government revenue it accounts
for the fact that some people may
actually work less if they find out that
their top income is going to be taxed at
seventy percent
but even accounting for that it is going
to generate the most revenue for the
government we can debate whether it's
ethical we can debate whether it's fair
I'm fine having that debate but to argue
that rich people are simply going to
leave the country or that rich people
are going to stop working if we put in
place something like a seventy percent
top marginal tax rate it's simply not
backed by the data I've seen if you have
different data I should look at let me
know and I'm glad to review and change
my mind if the data warrants that we
have a great bonus show for you today
make sure you are signed up for a
membership at join pakman.com you will
be treated to a producer Pat hosted
bonus show today and then I will be back
with you on the bonus show on Monday